veterans of the front line
taking a moment's rest before heading
back to the fight
though for now they're only acting
it's a film about ukraine's war with
russian-backed separatists in the east
yet many of these actors have fought in
the actual conflict
life and art intertwined
they're also ready to switch mock guns
for real ones again if needed
we wait with our military backs every
day and i'm ready in one second back to
my brigade and
take a
weapon and resist for russian aggression
it's not just a challenge for ukraine
this minister was previously a top
officer in the ukrainian equivalent of
mi5 and she has a warning if russia will
invade you know
you should also take care now about
balkans
what russians are doing now in serbia
they try to provoke
situation in balkans but we also
take into
the account
for the second beginning well i mean i
don't want to over exaggerate but is
there a chance that an invasion in
ukraine could even trigger a world war
iii yeah
yeah
because
geopolitically it looks like the
like possible scenario
despite the gloomy words the streets of
kiev feel more festive than fearful
yes vladimir putin has mobilized tens of
thousands of troops and moved tanks
closer to ukraine's border but some here
suspect the russian president might
simply be bluffing using the threat of
an attack as a weapon in itself to alarm
the west into agreeing to new demands
that would further weaken this country
without the need for all-out war
[Music]
a former leader in ukraine's 2014
revolution says putin's actions have
already grabbed the attention of the u.s
president downwards
it's very typical uh soviet russian
approach for
you know to
just create that
military threat you know and to start
looking for concessions
[Music]
whether through bluster belligerence or
both this crisis with russia is real and
very unpredictable debra haynes sky news
kiev